Short and sweet number 12. In a situation where it was possible that a non-mevushal open bottle of wine was touched by a non-Jew, it depends on the type of non-Jew who possibly touched it.
If it was possibly touched by a Christian, so then Rav Ovadya told us that for the Sfardim, the wine is forbidden to drink and even to get benefit from, while the Rama held that wine would be permissible.
If it was possibly touched by a Muslim, everybody agreed that the wine is permitted.
We then discussed the question of irreligious Jews, particularly Jews who are Mechalei Shabbos B'Far Hesya, which means that they desecrate Shabbos publicly in front of ten people at least three times.
So then we know that for the Din of the Gemara, that any wine that is touched by a Mechalei Shabbos B'Far Hesya, the wine is forbidden to drink, but it still is permitted to get benefit from.
However, again, we cannot drink it.
Or Shternbach does tell us that it's best not to get benefit from the wine if there's no need, but the minimal is that the wine would be prohibited to drink.
We discussed what is considered a Michal Shabbos B'Far Hesya b'Zman Hazet in current times.
So we said that there are really basically, in the general sense, there are four types of irreligious Jews.
The first type is the traditional Jew.
That would be someone who, although they are not Shabbos observant, they will go to shul, they recite Kiddush, they will do traditional practices.
However, they just don't keep Shabbos and they transgress it publicly.
The next category was what we call the respectful Jew.
That's someone who, again, they do not keep Shabbos.
They will be Michal Shabbos before Heser in public, but they would not do so in front of a Rav or someone that they respect.
The third category was the totally unaffiliated Jew or the Tinov SheNizhba.
They do not have a Jewish upbringing.
They do not have a Jewish education.
They will deliberately transgress Shabbos even in front of a Rav.
But again, they're not doing it out of spite, they just did not have the proper education or sensitivity to Shabbos.
The last category was the Mummer L'Hachas, a person who is the anti-religious Jew.
He had a Jewish education, they rejected it, and are now deliberately transgressing Shabbos, and they would do so even in front of a Rav.
So the status of the first three, the traditional Jews, the respectful Jews, and the Tinek Shinizhba,
we said was a machlokas between the poskim, whether or not they would prohibit wine that they touched.
However, we did say that the Mumra L'Chachis, this anti-religious Jew, if he would touch wine, everybody agrees that is a case that the wine would be forbidden to drink.